demasiado asustados para decirle a
vladimir putin la verdad sobre la guerra
esa es la afirmación de los funcionarios
de inteligencia estadounidenses sobre si
los asesores del presidente ruso le
están dando la información precisa esto
estaría provocando tensiones entre putin
y la cúpula militar rusa a medida que
aumentan los interrogantes sobre la
relación del presidente con su ministro
de defensa
sergei shoigú desapareció de la vista
del público durante semanas solo para
reaparecer en una sesión informativa
emitida el martes y obviamente tenemos
información que ahora hemos hecho
pública de que se sintió engañado por
los militares rusos creemos que está
siendo mal informado por sus asesores
sobre lo mal que está actuando el
ejército ruso y como la economía rusa
está siendo paralizada por las sanciones
porque de nuevo sus asesores de alto
nivel tienen demasiado miedo a decir la
verdad es una opinión compartida por la
inteligencia británica el jefe de
servicios de espionaje dice que putin
cometió un enorme error de cálculo al
juzgar la situación en ucrania y ahora
sus tropas están desmoralizadas y
desordenadas
y hemos visto a los soldados rusos
faltos de armas y de moral negándose a
cumplir órdenes saboteando su propio
equipo e incluso derribando
accidentalmente sus propios aviones
lo que está pasando y el alcance de
estos errores deben quedar muy claros
para el régimen de beijing russian negó
la veracidad de los informes
significa que ni el departamento de
estado y el pentágono poseen la
información real sobre lo que está
sucediendo en el kremlin simplemente no
entienden lo que está pasando en el
kremlin no entienden al presidente
moscú sigue defendiendo que su operación
especial militar es un éxito y asegura
que ahora concentrará sus actividades en
el donbass